let's keep taking calls I will go to the
269 area code next caller what is your
name and where you calling from uh my
name is Jade from Michigan okay what's
on your mind on who who has the
authority or the power to implement
voting as a national holiday and what
would be your strategy or suggestions to
get that done okay who has the authority
I don't know too much about the creation
of national holidays although I know
that our elected officials in the House
of Representatives do get to vote of you
you remember controversies over who
voted for and against Martin Luther King
Day being a holiday when they were in in
the House or Senate so clearly they're a
part of this thing although I don't know
what legislative process is necessary to
to create the initial bill do you know
Pat I mean I would guess that if
constituents go to their elected
officials the House and Senate can
propose bills to make X Day a national
holiday and they vote for way they vote
on it right i'm sure the process is just
like anything else and i think that's
what we saw with the creation of martin
luther king day and yeah it is important
that we make election day either a
national holiday or I think move it from
Tuesday to the weekend to a weekend yet
both both their ideas I mean in terms of
what we can do to push that listen uh we
know that one party benefits from lower
turnout and that's the Republican Party
or or the more conservative candidate
who happens to be on the ballot so we
have some pretty significant incentives
uh for conflict in terms of doing
something that would clearly increase
voter turnout at the individual person
level you call your elected officials
both senators and members of Congress
and say make voting day a federal
holiday I don't care whether you put it
on the weekend on a Tuesday but make it
a federal holiday of course moving it
from a Tuesday would also require a
whole other change to our legal system
because it's the tuesday after the first
monday in November is when election day
is and you would have to change that so
there's a lot to it interestingly enough
okay though that was all I wanted to
know thank you alright thank you so much
for the call really appreciate it thanks
for watching this video before you watch
the next one remember we're raising
money to expand the david pakman
big league as well as expand progressive
activism go to david pakman.com slash
donate donations of any size are much
appreciated